today we're going to do it on one of my
favorite players
Richard rady rady or not here we go rady
was also a great problem composer his
brother was also a well-known musician
and it's pretty funny
rady has like a thing over the letter
you know like one of those things that
makes no sense
all the noir people have them yeah like
brain-damaged I assume anyway his
brother didn't have that he's like I
don't want that so there you go now one
thing I learned about rady today was he
died very young I thought he was still
alive but it turned out he died in 1929
yeah that's right at the age of 40 of
scarlet fever he's listed like say yeah
yeah you agree with that people get that
now anyone not one person in like of 10
years it's all gone because they still
got the bubonic plague they still got it
yeah we got it
yeah I I would know yeah no scarlet
fever all gone wouldn't a rare like only
like a million people a year now kick
alright so ray D died very young but he
had a lot of great chess games probably
his most famous game was the obvious
game I was referring to which we will
see later was the game ready B kappa
blanka breaking kappa blanka's streak of
800 years without a loss something like
that or seven alright right arjun
alright so rabies white against either
rufus or doofus although his actual
names even funnier so that's caroli
sterk okay exactly yeah okay alright so
ii for x clam now rady played everything
so you had to be ready for everything
right Arjun alright ee five and they
played just like they play now 1910
modern chess they even even play the
Berlin
d six now I like this game but I have
one reason why I like it anybody now
rady played perfect every move that's
good that's good job okay d 4x clam
black pinned himself so we have to
punish that with d4 Bishop to d7
unpinning Knight c3 developing a piece
now the intelligent players in this room
would be like takes takes here and then
they would be like I don't know and they
play one of them when their flag would
fall except for argent but white plays
Knight c3 because you should develop
pieces in chess alright Bishop e7 Bishop
g5 black takes Knight takes castles
Bishop takes Bishop takes c6 is an
important move in these variations
because white gets one advantage or
another either we get f5 if the bishop
takes or if the pawn takes that as true
we would say black structure is no
family guy people here why maybe
lecturing okay at least at home you said
it ruined alright so BC doubled pawns
isolated pawn bishops aren't very good
okay he doesn't he doesn't stack paper
to the ceiling he doesn't write on 24
inch chrome he's got nothing 1910 what
kind of car do you have what do you
think Arjun terrible right no car right
and I got a look at this chess game they
should pay me more right all right Queen
d3 connecting the rooks now the rooks
can go in the middle the Queen can go
checkmate the King everybody's happy
Knight g4 terrible Arjun
right that goes without saying
all right so now we have a discovered
attack because I just discovered it this
ship takes let's see who can I call him
ken west what did black play you know he
did Queen takes bishop but I had them
all right now unlike everybody else in
the room rady played the best move here
you guys never played the best move here
I never saw you do it
Arjun incorrect not incorrect who I no
wonder you beat everybody
f4 ok I know that's why you beat
everybody so the knight ones to go to e5
the Queen wants to go to e5 not anymore
and White has more pawns on the Kings
side because I said so so white should
move his King side pawns
he's got more space he's got more force
and black resigned let's look at the
next game no I'm kidding f5 terrible
that's ok now didn't
rady follow my role no but why I wasn't
all ivy to know about it what's my rule
Arjen incorrect yeah you're getting at
the wrong rule going on here yeah see if
he played Bishop f1 here then he would
be a good adherence of my rules
you always play each takes f5 not always
take on f5 yeah II takes f5 ok now if
you had done that he'd be the greatest
player ever but nobody thinks he's the
greatest player ever so he played like
Paul Morphy instead what would Morphy do
here in a second
in a second right but which one yeah
yeah Rick is that that rook as Anand has
told me many times is doing Viswanathan
now it's on a 1 so now it's getting
hooked up over here alright this rook on
the other hand yeah alright I take you
you take me Queen h4 Grandmaster Kenda
wast what's the threat check me did rady
see it and be funnier if he didn't all
right then why am i showing this game h3
retreat like a come on didn't you read
your lines yesterday all right now all
beginners without thinking always trade
everything okay that's all they ever do
but you may have noticed earlier in the
game black played f5 f5 weakens which
Square this isn't a Ken West question
Arjun partial credit
partial credit you well some yeah I
agree with that
you ease 6yz that's what you said and
then I got a translate you know alright
so yeah yeah we'll give the right answer
next time alright so now you can see
with these lines that there's an arrow
to Black's King and black reason
no it's white smooth so white played the
obvious move you Knight g5 now we're
going to go to e6 and we're going to
play rugby 7 and everybody's happy
everybody Arjun he look he got his hand
is like wait a minute all right
d5 that's an important move 96 attacking
everything it texts this in this and as
the kids in my camp would say and this
and they would say it all right
yeah no no they're not which one this
night all right if you have been to
chess camp you'll never get it all right
Bishop takes and now the class is going
to vote you could vote for Knight takes
c6 or rook takes c6 I'll let you think
about it awhile I get paid by the hour
so
nails are pretty good hey did I ask for
a vote yet you can't vote early voting
hasn't opened yet
TIPA TIPA colum Eric and Pablo can't
listen alright and we and we have more
people to vote now you can vote for
Knight takes rook tanks now when I did
this in my camp they all voted for the
one in green whatever the position was
because greens better than red according
to them I am who votes for Knight takes
c6 vishwanadh buddy and who votes for
rook tanks it's ubiquitous it's
omnivorous and as usual the class is
totally right rook takes a six now this
pawn is weak now what fine gold rule
would lead you to play rook takes six
you have to use a negative inference
here very complicated to figure out my
rules you know I'll give you a hint it's
not chopsticks and it's not a spoon it's
not a fork knife f5 so you can't play
knife f5 if you're Knights on e6 alright
man Knight f5 is going to be knife a57
me a radiant vented knife f5 alright c5
attacking the knight oh no where does it
go I have five BAM I now the beat down
followed by the Smackdown took plays
queen h5
yeah yeah
and what did white play
now they agreed to a draw what g4 was
May Larsen I don't see him
you guys are assuming I remember what he
played terrible audience yes no no I
know you what Ricky seven I don't know
the answer you who's the comedian over
here Gaia
anyway white played everybody's hoping
they're right rook f6 oh so close
and black played grande mr. can West
I'll give you two guesses two guesses
yes correct
very good if rook takes f6 Queen takes
deef Queen takes d5 check is reasonable
because the rooks not defending other
rook and if G takes f6 which then he
can't raise his hand quick enough yeah
live a queen on h5 you should trade
Queens I have a question this point of
f6 where was it
is it there now yeah so what's the right
move Arjun yeah
don't you hate when that happens so King
h8 is risky Queen g6 is also risky and
the riskiest of all is king f7 risk you
the King h8 yeah and now as Roman jinn
Josh feely would say yeah g4 wins rook
e1 wins
Queen e7 probably wins yeah yeah
probably moving the night away wins
night night g3 wins Queen g6 x Clem they
found it was it didn't win solid
yeah good job yeah you're better in one
sense all right so white one ray and
then the game's ended I don't know okay
now a play you've heard of target our
right no you what how could you lie to
my face like that what's his first name
tartar cow is his first name yeah that's
true
rady played Eve for what she always
played how that's funny because the
radio opening all right see six terrible
this is a very famous game that you all
know for example you know it right you
yeah the you don't point you do you do
know it yep yes you do
all right watch the apology later you
wait you were ready no no there's not
just this one you're going to agree that
you know the game was we keep looking at
it you hear me talking over there all
right
so the really know the girl con okay now
you know it exactly all right yeah no we
don't talk about French in this class
yeah it's not allowed hope it's not
Joseph French oh that's okay then yeah
then you're you're back in all right now
rady played the most common move all
right what's the least common move white
can play that doesn't hang everything
it's less common than what you're going
to suggest it's much less common than
that you much less common now you're
queuing your night never play f3 Queen
d3 say what all right so ready or not
here comes Queen d3 you know the game
yeah
what you know okay now black blundered
every movie is out of his prep out of
his preppy blunders he played 'if I've
double question mark if I give a double
question work that was like chess pays
okay and radies like thank you very
polite d take c5 now black played the
trick of the century
tricking himself queen a5 check winning
back his pawn draw agreed
Bishop to d2 you know the game yet yeah
the most famous game ever
what do you want throw any people all
right Queen takes e5 and now tiger
collar started trash-talking he's like
look at all these threats I got right
he's got I got all these heroes yeah ah
now the light comes on right Arjen okay
so now white does something I always
teach he avoids a hassle castles I said
that once in kids class and this kid
raised his hand and said what's a hassle
and then when I said Castle they said
what's castling yeah all right now black
one apiece ooh okay nine takes tonight
you know this game yet yeah no nothing
all right nothing Danny you got nothing
all right now other than Julian who has
seen the game knows the answer anyway
what move did white make argent have you
seen this Arjun are you telling the
truth because somebody put the one of
the lights on Argent's we can see be
telling the truth you Arjun ah hold on
at three even worse
I've never been so furious I would
someone like to suggest the actual move
played in the game Arjun wait now you
know the game on the apology I'll wait
okay
ah now you're like I don't know this
game now you know the game you didn't
know his radio tartakower you didn't
know it's ready tower to counter those
guys were good well maybe that's harder
camera
after this game you gotta like say whoa
tartakower dude
alright you Queen da BAM right Arjun you
get it yet really even King c7 okay
alright so black played the best to move
takes so white sacrificed his Queen and
now he's all lined up now what the ship
f4 wins the Queen but there's one thing
better than winning the Queen Arjun
Bishop d5 double check which makes sense
because rady died in Prague true story
that's true the country he was born in
no longer exists yeah alright now we got
two mates in one kingi a rug da mate or
the actual game king c7 Arjun Bishop d8
me solid and charter car was good yeah
ex clam all right what a game what a guy
now he played everybody's favorite
opponent and N and this was an offhand
game you
I don't know you thought I was crazy
then he showed up alright efore we're
ready plays he for every game he five
the knight c3 Bishop c5 now I tell my
kids Bishop c5 question mark and they
raise their hand and go what is Bishop
c5 mean what's question mark mean so it
doesn't really help
okay arjan's hands way up yeah what is
what you do you sure
are you positive okay Knight takes e5
alright now that's called the fork trick
and I can't show you the fork unless
black lets it happen so black might
happen very nice of him okay and vision
Knight takes e5 d4 now blacks only
slightly worse here but since his name
is NN is a really bad track record over
a period of hundreds of years plays
terrible really did he wake up and
apologize alright Bishop Bishop takes d4
terrible Queen takes Queen f6 now for
those of you who are the uninitiated
black has a threat here again these
queens are lined up so can't jump over
the night if white plays the most
obvious move rook to be one well you
want to overprotect b2 then Knight f3
check forking the king and queen I
didn't see pawn takes Knight but luckily
I have Queen takes Queen very lucky okay
so ladies like you can't play Queen f6
I'm ready and you're a ten what chance
do you have so ready attacked and defend
it at the same time how did he save his
Queen and make threats you
haha coral the worst player in this
chair stop jumping up and down at home I
can't hear you oh I can hear you
obviously ex clan because II 1 & 2 moves
better than you you would want like
three moves right now this trick doesn't
work anymore because the Queen's
protected and black got worried about
night here quiet in class please
now black should play c6 giving away the
d6 square but instead of you lost
immediately because it's better for our
class and played King to d8x clam now as
my favorite line of The Sopranos there's
good and there's not good that's not
good okay that's the worst however which
first world champion approved of King g8
so he gave the answer onus of the first
world champion you George Washington
that's right yeah he was good friends
with Ben Franklin's in the Hall of Fame
some of those statements were true not
many I said the first world champion not
the first president also the first
president was John Hanson read your
history what right bet are you backing
me up there you go you yeah yeah you
know kind of low Congress at all all
right so now if I was white I would play
Queen f8 mate but I'm a grandmaster
you're not also I would play house it
away I would play Queen takes e7 Shack
I'm sort of giving you the answer so
therefore white played Canwest
how do you white thread them both he's
like now you can do it
Queen c5 Mario yeah now now it's tough
and how things are tough I tells you and
now black do we all yearn to do resign
my my favorite variation is
the obvious night here check here check
castles here maybe mate with advantage
and now the tables are turned
it was Queen now it's like that right
Arjen and then he ran the bases it was a
home run
is that right Arjun I okay I now in this
position White's down a piece but he has
a threat that you see and a fraud that
you don't see you're like I see them
both can I can I set this up before you
give the wrong answer alright so the
bishop wants to take the Queen and here
black has an intermezzo where doesn't
get checkmated immediately but that
wouldn't be any fun for our class so he
didn't do that black should play Bishop
g5 check okay then maybe he's better
instead he moved his queen moving his
queen when it's attacked terrible queen
bee 7x glam all right now white gives
black the sugar me do okay it looks like
blacks King is safe because all these
pieces are here but I know it's not safe
because I heard a long discussion
between Laurence Olivier and Dustin
Hoffman it's definitely not safe right
you hear me talking over there Ken West
no don't know the Marathon Man really
yeah that's recess is it safe that's the
one thing you know you still didn't get
it
ah ah you it's the right answer Queens
you know if only if only aren't you two
down that you have you two given the
wrong answer right yeah I know
queen g6 check now if King eh a X clam
me double X clam so even better and if
Bishop takes Queen he take towards the
center doubled pawns
okay hg six I can't fit all King h8 and
now blacks the queen up so white resign
is what you don't agree what do you do
stalemate no no no yeah he lived in
Prague so checkmate
never mind hi and and white wins because
he's got slight attack Queen b7 no good
now for the famous game
rady kappa blanka new york 1924 which
was won by which player given like come
on that was a good guess
it was a wrong answer but a good guess
who there is there wasn't one of these
two guys the big three played in New
York 24 who were the big three I'll give
you in world champions two three and
four all right the correct answer
obviously is Emanuel asker right right
obviously okay Lasker cab blank Alec I'm
pretty good tournament anyway kappa
blanka supposedly hadn't lost a game in
a thousand years and then rady took him
to school picked him up at 3:30 sharp
okay and in fact he played the rady
finally efore his whole life what's he
doing now
where's Kokomo now okay that gives you a
hint as to what White's next move was
yes before good job yeah okay some
people like space some people don't
okay my ex-girlfriend for example I'll
never mind alright Bishop g7 now for his
black smooth and that's something else
okay Bishop b2 yeah and they play boring
because that's what kappa blanka did
alright
what oh this is like the boring world of
niels bohr over here alright
and nothing's happening nothing's
happening and finally d4 Bishop b4 the
Queen move pretty good takes takes now
it looks good for black cap a blank of
the best not whites better
well that's trick ended now White's
better not only because I said so
White has more space pawn on the fifth
rank fourth rank and this one's weak
terrible takes aa anti positional ah C
takes d4 terrible this should take c4
that's better now to weak pawns but
black gave himself the c5 square Queen
takes c4 what do we call that Arjun
greedy taking a weak pawn exposing your
Queen horrible Bishop g7 King g7 x clam
and now the winning move can argent find
it he's like I'm playing with this chair
over here yeah you know who can't find
it can west no I'm just kidding alright
now in this game the obvious move is
Knight takes Queen or ninety for his
Knight takes Queen because you fork the
Queen and the bishop if you don't like
that move this they could take the Queen
so this is a clearance move obviously
Arjun what that's what I think that I'm
probably both wrong a queen bee - well
you know now it's check and then Knight
d2 is coming don't you hate when that
happens
how could kappa blanka be so greedy to
take this pawn and not only that he set
himself up to do it by playing CD
terrible okay the thing is queen shake
c4 is usually good he just wasn't ready
right arjun is kappa blanka yeah yeah
that's slightly different yeah yeah your
sense of humor is very suspicious very
suspicious
alright Queen B - King GA and now every
move wins especially yeah
I was waiting for that T to be that's
funny
Knight 3d - I don't know what he played
Rick takes d6 ah he showed you on 92
looks good
what's the winning move for black does
it wing move for black I was kidding you
know I think black could play Queen c2
based on what t-shirt yes what no it
said Queen c2 X clam yeah come on learn
my life now if we trade both rooks are
hanging OH
Kappa blank is too good so rook takes d6
bam Queen c5 attacking the rook rook a
d1 radies threatening to win two pieces
for a rock rook a 7 defending 93 and
black is crushed because I got the
diagonal I got the file here comes
Knight g4 okay a terrible b6 is weak
neither Knight can move and all the
euros are going that way terrible
all right queen h5 threatening the
knight Knight d4 unthreatening the
knight takes takes knight c6 is crushing
the Knights still can't move Knight c4
double X clam if 96 forking the rook and
Queen
Julian's hand goes up really fast yeah
he takes Queen yeah 9 c4 Queen c5 now 96
man this is like Carlsen nobody that's
what it looks like all of whites pieces
are better than all blacks pieces but
Kappa blankets we made a lot of moves so
you got to give him that rook c7 saving
is ruck 93-95 Rick d5 and the black
queen is well placed well placed for
white to capture and Kappa blanket now
played the amazing move resigns offer
draw yeah yeah so that game he just got
B positionally strategically and it made
sure Lasker won the tournament
I wasn't sure who's going to win this
tournament and I didn't know so I'll ask
her when I found out right that's okay
Kappa Blanc it wasn't upset because
they'll always have parents right Ken I
can guide it good alright and last but
not least an unknown game played in
Bratislava
that's where Arjun likes to vacation
right yeah really okay
what okay see for why you see for good
how many times have I told this joke
how many never let's call on a random
student Julian thank you it controlled
e5i terrible answer I c5 Knight f3 I
like this game looks like it was played
today in my chest cam g6
okay now the age-old question occurs
should black play Bishop takes c3
ruining the pawn structure but getting
rid of his dark squared Bishop Julian
that's what he did yeah then you're
going to see how he gets the beat down
to the SmackDown but you're like my
blacks winning yeah yeah so now black
started you know moving his Knights
around Bob Seger was even born yet f3 d6
castles Knight a5 terrible all right
so in chess you should develop your
pieces in castle or you could show that
you know how the knight moves okay and
maybe that's why Bob Segar runs a song I
saw this game okay Bishop h6 now
castling is not good and illegal which
again would not stop anybody in my camp
well that's my camp you never know what
they'll do alright Bishop a6 now if you
remember the last position and you don't
the bishop was on e3 that was a hint
now what did white do was it was a hint
no see any attack this pawn and I e3
yeah he understands me all right rook ca
f4 put it in F F for is a very important
move because blacks King is on ei
and it's going to stay on e8
irrespective of Adams opinions it's
still going to be on
ei so White's going to push all the
center pawns open up the King on ei with
the flashing green light hey that was
1925 in Bratislava so and black loses
because all his pieces are on the Queen
side and white has the two bishops let's
see if it works
rook g8x clam now I'm just kidding it's
terrible and I've said this before I
used to be related to somebody and that
person would play rook GA and I say
you're now allowed to play rim g8 and
now we're not related
so then it's tough but fair okay and
hopefully my lawyer is watching this
video I Queen c2 of course as advertised
f6 never play F 6 e 5 the plaintiff f6
was to stop b5 that makes it fun here
and black wants to move his King closer
to White's pieces tank stakes f5 alright
and now if Vasily escaped rhodius isn't
watching this pause your video go give
him a call okay and then you cut on
vitam over and then have him come look
at this position and ask him what he
would play and the answer is knife f5
yeah yeah now black decided taking the
night was suicidal but still better than
what he did yeah he played 96 terrible
ok he should take and then man Bishop h5
check queen of Rikai yeah that terrible
terrible ah ok the game ended and really
was really funny how the game ended
that's why I like this game 96 93
defending the pawn or so he thought ok
now watch the end don't blink takes
takes for a d1 what did black by origin
no this is serious yeah
yeah now this is my favorite radium it's
unknown and here you did to something
beautiful although it was two nights
against two bishops I should be a little
more angry I like two nights I know
white sacrificed his Queen here not easy
to do although he did win seven of
blacks pieces so he played Queen a4
check and black played the obvious move
any one you I don't care who answers
anybody Queen c6 yeah and now what's the
winning Queen sacrifice and your hands
always up you Bishop c4 yeah and black
resigned Queen c4 is illegal and
therefore not good it's better than
right now after but there's a recon yet
oh yeah you're right
alright now Bishop takes c6 two bishops
for a queen and blacks King is well
placed for white to checkmate him I
didn't finish my sentence what we play
chess before
now we're threatening maiden one who
wants to find it is there more than one
main one Adam the ship f7 me now how do
you stop it should have seven me so yeah
but that doesn't stop me Arjen
yeah then man this should take g7 that's
we called The Horizon effect no but
what's the best of according to the
computer ah man Mario instantly
that's right computer with his Queens XD
one yeah Mario knows what's up
then after here you're slightly worse
yeah and now you're not so good yeah
there's goodness yeah so I I really like
the end of the game Queen Shaq this
should take c4 and the guy didn't like
hook him up he resigned like let's think
I get this position that's awesome
you're threatening Bishop f7 me and both
rooks solid that's a good King on ei
back to the question at hand what do you
think a Bishop takes c3 didn't work out
well come on that guy play great after
that all right and his name was Rufus
okay and but he prepared this variation
with Chaka Khan class dismissed